hello everyone and welcome to today's
black broadcast image based screening
for precision medicine and immunotherapy
presented by dr. Greta grief Latimer CSO
and scientific co-founder of sight I'm
Alexis Krause of lab routes and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is brought to
you by laberd's and sponsored by
PerkinElmer PerkinElmer is a global
leader committed to innovating for a
healthier world their innovative
detection imaging informatics and
service capabilities combined with deep
market knowledge and expertise how
customers gain earlier and more accurate
insights will prove lives in the world
around us for more information about our
sponsor please visit PerkinElmer calm
now let's get started before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send who answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the answer your
question box located on the far left ear
screen this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits I'd like to now introduce our
presenter dr. Gregory vladimer Gregory
vladimer is the CSO and scientific
co-founder of all sight in vienna
austria where high throughput and high
content confocal microscopy of primary
patient samples is used in order to
define drug action at single-cell
resolution dr. vladimir received his PhD
in immunology for the program in innate
immunity of the Department of Medicine
at the University of Massachusetts
Medical School
prior to his postdoctoral work at the
Center for molecular medicine and
of the Austrian Academy of Sciences dr.
Vladimir and his colleagues performed
what they believed was the first
prospective study assessing the
feasibility and efficacy of ex vivo drug
response profiling to guide personalized
treatment selection across large panels
of possible treatments for patients
suffering aggressive hematological
malignancies published at the intern
stage last year and Lansing hematology
the methodology for the screening was
invented by a team of scientists
medicine including professor dr. Bryn
Snyder dr. Nicholas crawl and professor
dr. Giulio super fatigue verga the team
is now focused on determining the
feasibility of deploying such image
based single-cell screening assays into
the clinical round for patients with
various malignancies for the complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
dr. vladimer you may now begin your
presentation great thank you so much for
the introduction
so all sites as was just mentioned is a
spin-off company of sem the center from
Luxor medicine at the Austrian Academy
of Sciences and today I'll talk about a
number of stories that we've done or
performed at SEM and collaboration with
the medical university of vienna
department of hematology and he missed a
theology so with that these are my
disclosures I'm a shareholder an
employee of all sight in Vienna so one
of the aims of my work and also also its
work is to improve the translate ability
of free clinical research we believe
that there's a high unmet need for model
systems that better recapitulate the
complexity of human disease are more
predictive of clinical outcome than
currently available cell line and animal
models and further that modeling human
immune function has proven particularly
challenging and when looking at
technologies like PDX
derived patient samples or humanized
mouse or human s animal models they're
limited in throughput and they have a
long tumor passages that may skew
results so today I'm going to talk about
a technology that we call from Acosta P
this is single cell imaging technology
platform that can profile drug action
directly in primary cancer patient
samples we
high throughput with minimum amounts of
sample minimal incubation times to
reduce adaptation to execute conditions
and we use this to get a preview of
activity of the drug activity or
stimulant activity directly in human
samples so this is an overview of my
talk today I'll discuss the technology
applications and then I'll move on to
the interim analysis of a clinical trial
called exalt to reprioritized
interventions for patients with late
stage hematological malignancies and
I'll talk a little bit about resulting
drug resistance Maps the integration of
multi omics data sets into our screening
data to rationally identify drug
combinations and then lastly the
investigation of mechanisms of
immunomodulatory drugs through measuring
the physical interactions of cells so
this is an overview of the from a costly
technology that we'll discuss
samples are taken from patients their
blood or bone marrow samples homogenized
lymph tissue purely fusion or ascites
samples and then we purify up
mononuclear cells these contain cancer
cells and also healthy cells there's no
other cell sorting or outgrowth that's
just a fight call gradient to remove
those mononuclear cells and they're put
into plastic 384 well imaging plates
clear plastic bottom and a black surface
these the dogma originally for high
content screening was that adherent cell
lines must be used to obtain in
imageable mono layer that can be stained
looking for pathways or cells of
interest or phenotypes of interest we
broke that dogma and are now able to
create a monolayer of non-adherent
cellular material that we can fix in
place and stained with antibodies
against cell surface receptors
phosphorylation events or other things
we want to look at so after they're
fixed and stained we image them and they
run through an image analysis pipeline
that we'll discuss in a moment and we
can do normal at the bottom of the
plates you'll see we can do normal image
analysis of cell size of morphology
surface marker expression signaling
events or translocation of protein
translocation and phosphorylation events
but through the image analysis of these
particular images of we call from a
constantly we can also pull
two other scores in the top right hand
side you'll see a drug response score
this is the XP of a measurement of
differential killing potential of
anti-cancer drugs that I'll show you we
can correlate two clinical responses in
our interim Basket trial and then the
second below that is the spatial
interaction score this is the
quantification of immune synapse
formation as a novel measure of
immunomodulation so literally measuring
social contacts so I want to talk about
a little bit of the data that we're
collecting we do consider this to be big
data so we perform these assays in 300
384 well plates if we assume that we're
utilizing a 10x objective we image each
well four times it's 2x2 overlapping
overlapping matrix so we gather all the
information from the entire bottom of
the well we do this in five color
channels and that is really the capacity
of our microscope is five color channels
or five channels and so every 90 minutes
we're collecting 7680 images if we can
run our platform at 24 hours we have two
microscopes that do this that's 32
plates in per day that's 240 5,000
images per day which is about 12
terabytes of raw imaging data per month
now the analysis of these images again
since we're looking at precision
medicine and we're looking at how drugs
affect or how we can put data into the
clinic we need to be quick about this
and the analysis if we analyze a single
plate on an eight-core workstation that
would take about 45 hours but we can
bring this it down to about 30 minutes
using an expandable cloud-based system
that meets EGU healthcare data privacy
laws and more information about that
program can be found on our website
looking at the data points now for so
that we're collecting if we consider
that we look at let's say 10,000 cells
per well we're looking at about two
point one times ten of the dates ten
data points collected per day we're also
then trying to integrate those data
points that we collect from imaging into
the genetics again I'll talk about that
so we do consider this to be fairly big
data so let's get into now we're doing
with these programs and the first one is
the exalt trial so prioritizing
intervention for patients with late
stage hemant illogical malignancies
now I have a little bit here on the
current take on precision medicine and
cancer and the debate on ex vivo chemo
sensitivity screening has been going on
for some time I'd like to show this
paper from the 1980s and the any jam a
critical appraisal of the human tumor
stem cell assays ELISA assays have been
around for a long time so if we talk to
now about a paper that has been
published a little bit more recently
looking at precision medicine for cancer
with next-generation functional
diagnostics when we consider itself a
next-generation functional test we're
kind of working an uphill battle
situation where limited clinical testing
hampers the setup of clinical trials and
the lack of clinical trials limits the
understanding of reliability but tests
in the functional realm that have come
before us look at population level
statistics or population level responses
and what we're doing is we're looking at
single cell level responses and I'll
tell you a little bit about what we're
measuring on the next slide here so by
utilizing image based screening we can
mark the cancer cells in the well using
antibodies against diagnostic markers
for instance if a pathologist uses cd34
and city 117 to diagnose acute myeloid
leukemia those are the cell populations
that we would be looking at now in our
microscope so we're looking for drugs
that are killing off those marker
positive cells and this would be on
target on the left hand side of this
figure here drugs that are doing nothing
will be inactive and drugs that are
killing off healthy cells or diagnostic
marker negative cells would be toxic or
that are generally set a toxic and this
way we can utilize the healthy cells
that are inherent to the patient sample
as the internal control for our assay
instead of using either just vehicle
DMSO or media or comparing two healthy
human donors so we're ultimately
measuring is a relative cancer fraction
or relative cell fraction which is the
percent of live cancer cells over or of
the total number of cells under drug
treatment over the percentage of live
cancer cells of total cells under
control we can then rank what we're
testing it in this case small molecule
drugs by their efficacy of killing off
cancer cells versus healthy cells on the
right hand side you'll see that and we
can then say
drugs that kill off more cancer cells
leaving the healthy cells alone have a
favorable clinical outcome and drugs
that have a poor clinical outcome
probably have either killed all of the
cells or were generally cytotoxic to
healthy cells
so using the scoring system we set up a
clinical trial that you see the
organization and overview here starting
at the left hand side of the diagram the
patient comes in this patient who had a
relapse refractory blood cancer so it
was a basket trial focused around
hematological malignancies informed
consent was collected and the biopsy was
taken again the biopsy depends on the
clinical manifestation of the cancer and
then we screened the sample through on
average about a hundred and thirty a
clinically approved drugs or clinically
obtainable drugs looking specifically at
the drugs ability to kill off cancer
cells this data went into an exalt orde
this was exactly like the normal tumor
board except for the fact that they also
had another piece of data which was ours
and then we determined after that if the
conclusion criteria of this study were
met and in this case it was two or more
prior treatment lines so the patient was
multi relapsed and no further standard
treatments available so they were off
quite Landon therapy if the inclusion
criteria were met they could enter the
farmer classically got a treatment and
if they were not met they entered a
physician's choice arm so generally the
treatment of late stage hematological
cancer patients with drugs and
combinations predicted to be effective
using from a constantly that was the
goal of the study and each patients
response and PFS is compared to the
previous line of the same patient so we
didn't have a randomized cohort here we
use it each patient as their own control
model and you can see here are the
interim results of this study on the
left hand side you have the best overall
response rate from this cohort and again
we're comparing the previous line of
therapy to our line of therapy so one
line of therapy longer so in the Left
bar here on the left hand side of the
figure the left bar you see the most
recent regiment so you have progressive
disease stable disease and pre remission
for best overall response rate and on
the right-hand bar you see our from a
cost be guided treatment you see stable
disease partial response and complete
remission so even though these patients
are one line of therapy farther along in
their treatment plan they're doing
better on the overall response and they
were previously now on the right-hand
side we've the same cohort this is
progression free survival so the
kaplan-meier doesn't show death in this
case each
is an event so it's a relapse the dark
blue line is the most recent regiment so
you can see the patients were relapsing
through there against drug treatment and
the light blue line is a Pharma
constantly guided treatment so not only
did they have a patient to a better
overall response rate but they lasted
longer then on they lasted longer to
relapse than on their most recent
regimens so patients receiving from a
cost could be based treatments of a
higher chance of response and have a
longer PSS in previous rounds of therapy
going to give two examples here of two
of the patients in the study so the top
patient had a diffuse large b-cell
lymphoma Multi relapsed we looked at the
effect of a hundred and four drugs on
cd20 positive cells and you can see the
second hit here is a Bruton tip Bruton
of had was the second best and killing
off cd20 positive cells versus other
cells in the in the plate the first was
cisplatin the patient couldn't perceive
that because of their age on the left
hand on the right hand side of this
figure and but on the left hand side
you'll see the PET CT in this dotted
square you'll see the the cancer here
that was before treatment after the
Tribune received after the patient
received a Bruton tip they're opee they
entered complete remission you can see
it on the right hand side here on the
bottom you see a patient blbl this
patient again multi relapsed and they
had a presenting with a pure love fusion
we collected that material for screening
and screen them through 266 drugs and
this was actually a library not just of
anti-cancer drugs but of many drugs but
of the anti-cancer drugs bortezomib and
six McAfee purium or some of the top
hits we prioritize those drugs for this
patient and this patient entered
remission they did not end up entered
entering complete remission but they
were in palliative care and could go
home afterwards so these are just two
examples responses from both stage
patients in the cohorts so we also see
that we can predict therapy responses in
this mixed basket trial if we take a
look at the four groups of patients that
we have patients that entered
progressive disease stable disease
partial response and complete remission
and we take a look at all of the drugs
that were treated with you'll see that
in these two cases the patients were
actually
treated with combinations although we
were not screening in combinations but
if we take a look at the partial
response here the top of blue dot is the
pharma cost be guided treatment this is
an example patient who received picks in
turn an ideal alison and we sum these
scores up we can predict that the
patient will enter at least some sort of
good response profile versus a patient
who received I let's say a negative
score from their combination therapy on
the left hand side and they grade I
you'll see the patient entered
progressive disease we can predict how
well these patients will do and we can
do this on the right hand side you'll
see that a 92% accuracy at least between
PD versus PR + CR and the area under the
curve here was a 0.84 so it's not just
one-off drug treatment but we can
actually look to predict how well these
patients will do under the therapy
guidelines under the therapy treatments
so a byproduct of the screening is
fairly large drug response maps as you
see here and I don't expect you to read
or be able to read all of this although
it is published and you can take a look
at it but ultimately when you end up
with is per patient here a finger print
of response we are not the ones are not
even close to the ones that coined the
term fingerprint for drug responses per
patient but I want you to look at the
architecture here of the response
because we're not only looking at cell
death we're looking at selective cell
death or general set of toxicity and
we've also layered that on or layered
that with the clinical response profiles
and so you can basically use this as
almost a map to off labeling and to give
you an example here if you can see this
line or this thread here this is
bortezomib where Tesman
blue means the drug did well it killed
off target cells the red is it had
general cytotoxicity and it's overlaid
with the therapy responses Green is good
red is not good with portes maybe you
see to do a lot of blue responses here
the drug does fairly well in each
patient and does also well clinically
and you can actually see an example of
this here bortezomib is approved for
motile myeloma we had one multiple
myeloma patient in this study this is
not it this is a nother diffuse large
b-cell lymphoma patient whom we often
live aboard
hasn't been before DLBCL we can see its
effectiveness so it's really a road map
or a guide to off-label in therapy that
we can produce here so if we think back
at the study overview you saw that we
recruited patients and then after
screening we determined if they met the
inclusion criteria so another byproduct
of that style workflow is if we end up
with a lot more data than we actually
give go into the clinic with the benefit
of that is that we can look at big data
in the sense of a lot of fingerprinting
so what I want to show you here is the
integrative axial differential drug
responses we're about six hundred and
twenty patient samples that are then
stratified or combined by their response
profiles so again blue is targeted red
is not targeted and these this is a
basket trout disease it's a lot of
indications here but I want you to pay
attention to something quite interesting
so this is what our architecture this is
with again this is differential drug
response score but if we take a look
just in general cell death if we
indiscriminately look at the cells and
we just see what drugs kill we actually
lose this style architecture we don't
see the same response profiles as we
would if we were using this differential
response core and this is quite
important in defining how drugs or use
or how we can off-label drugs in the
future and so we just said we consider
this to be fairly large data or fairly
big data but the one thing that's
missing here is the identification of a
target and can we use genetics to
stratify these patients or these
responses farther so the next thing I
want to talk about is the integration of
omics data sets in particular attack
sleep and I'll get into that in a second
into pharma costs we data to rationally
identify drug combinations this is a
prospective piece in nature medicine
that was published in 2017 and I just
like the title of a functional precision
cancer medicine moving beyond pure
genomics and I like this because what
we're trying to do here is not use pure
genomics and non use pure functional
screening but a combination of both of
these in order to better treat patients
or better find drugs that work so just
to introduce the story a little bit
we're looking at rational drug
combinations specifically for a Bruton
treated
chronic info classic leukemia so CLL is
characterized by a clonal proliferation
and accumulation of malignant B
lymphocytes where the interference of
the BCR signaling pathway provides
therapeutic benefits such as an
inhibitor against BTK such as a brew to
them which has demonstrated clinical
efficacy response to a routine M alone
can be slowed in complete however and
discontinuation can be associated with
rapid disease progression further
complete remission from opportunity is
rare or alone is rare and thus
combination treatments are used and a
number of clinical trial programs are
working to identify Aborigine
combination therapies and we wanted to
again integrate multi-omics datasets to
increase the likelihood of actionable
data or at least rationally find
therapeutics that we could combine with
the burden of clinically this is an
overview of the program this is papers
now impress in nature Chemical Biology
and so we did was we collected frozen
peripheral blood samples from patients
with CLL before they had gone undergone
a bruit to dip their opee and in three
weeks after they had undergone a Bruton
Avera P and we performed two things
before an epigenetic profiling with a
taxi as you can see on C on top so we
look for open chromatin chromatin states
or closed chromatin states and then we
did the chemo sensitivity profiling by
from across degrees so single cell
actually with differential cell
screening over about a hundred and
thirty one drugs at two concentrations
in 3d for role plates and we looked at
the cell death measured by or on target
versus off target cell death and when we
integrated these datasets together so
I'll go through some of the top level
data here for the sake of time hopefully
you can look at the paper soon I don't
know when it's coming online but
hopefully soon so if we take a look at
the attack safe data what we need to do
is we need to look at it from the
pathway level and we use the KEGG
pathway in order to determine or let's
say in order to find pathways that were
being modulated or mediated or changed
by a bird to them so we see that there's
increased accessibility here for the
proteasome and autophagy pathways cancer
associated transcription deregulation
you can see that on the top part of this
graph here and decrease accessibility
for metabolic processes such as there
synthesis or fatty acid degradation and
DNA repair an interesting hypothesis for
Bruton is of the cells that are treated
with a brute sedimentary quiescent state
and some of these decreased pathways
such as metabolic pathways and DNA
repair possibly foreshadow that or or
speak towards that and so here we have
the pathways that are changed at the
genetic level specifically the chromatin
level and the genetics provided their
correlative evidence but we need to find
other tools to have it positive so you
know what drugs can we use to target
these pathways so here's then the drug
screening data on the left-hand side
pardon me you'll see a selection of the
130 drugs and so we looked at
specifically the CD 19 and CD 5 positive
fraction of B cells and these were these
CLL cells for these patients and we
wanted to find drugs that again had a
higher cytotoxicity of the targeted
population after a birthdate of therapy
and things like proteasome inhibitors
such as our so submit the more teza mabh
the plk inhibitors philosophy of and vi2
536 and amatuer inhibitors all had a
higher targeted cytotoxicity of the
target population after brigitte of
therapy again in order to combine
datasets we had to look at what pathways
do these drugs affect and so we looked
at the KEGG pathways of the drug effects
in order to be integrate these two
datasets together and we see increased
sensitivity in the KEGG pathways such as
autophagy proteasome and not signal I
mean you can see some of the major
changes here so then upon integrating
these datasets which you see on this
slide here on one axis you see changes
in chemo sensitivity so on the left as
you go up we see drugs that are more
selective to killing off the CLL cells
after clinical Oberto nib and I'm going
to bottom out towards the right you see
open pathways that have become open
after clinical version of therapy and
thus in the top right hand corner you
see pathways that can be targeted both
by or that are opening and also can be
targeted after a break it up therapy and
thus we can utilize this to prioritize
drug treatment so again proteasome and
autophagy being some of the biggest hits
along with the mTOR mTOR pathways and
plk inhibitors
and then we could follow that off in a
synergy screen to confirm them why would
we saw ex vivo as far as bruton of
therapy clinically and then testing if
you go
we could also recapitulate in a
combination screen and here you see six
examples of that where we took some of
these top ket drugs from the pathway
prioritization and then repeated these
screenings to find drugs that would
increase in their specificity to kill
off CLL cells after clinical approach in
them again such as bortezomib in
purchasing them so to summarize this
first part is anti-cancer part from a
constabie single cell interrogation can
predict in vivo response profiles and
thus can be predictive of clinical
outcome at least in this basket trial
the system for drugged indication
matching and drug to patients
ratification could potentially enable
further off labeling studies and there's
a need for larger more systematic single
indication studies that follow really
following you us and beat your
diagnostic medical device laws and
something that we're aiming to do to see
what the clinical impact is of these
workflows lastly also the the
integration of chromatin accessibility
profiling by a taxi and a function of
drug testing can systematically identify
potential drug combinations and I want
to make a note that we used CLO and in
Bruton it as a proof-of-concept
indication to find frontal pathways but
the technology and this energy can be
combined for many indications and your
combinations in the future so I want to
change gears slightly for the last part
of the talk and this is investigating
the mechanisms of the MENA modulatory
drugs to be measuring literally the
social contacts or the physical contacts
with cells I'm a trained demonologist
and something that we always use to look
at activity or immune activity or
Eliza's in cytokine based readouts
soluble factors but some of the biggest
events in immunology are the ways that
cells communicate physically such as the
innate to adaptive immune system and
then the propagation of immune responses
through the MHC to the the t-cell
receptor and these things aren't usually
looked at but we can
a lot especially but immunomodulation
for measuring social contacts and so
again the immune system depends on
soluble factors but also once also
contacts to function and social
interactions importantly are the basis
of immunotherapies by specifics bring
selves together and affect yourself
kills a target cell now the way that
parties work the party goes in
physically interacting the cancer cell
then kills it
but there's currently that we're aware
of a know high throughput way to
systematically measure these social
interactions when we can utilize another
image based workflow and analysis
algorithm to measure social contact
changes upon treatment with molecules by
logic small draws molecule drugs to
infer immunomodulatory properties and
this is the workflow here now it's the
same as you saw previously but the maths
a little different on the back end so I
want to take a look at an example image
here and this is one-fourth of one image
of about 7,500 so one plate and I want
to draw your attention to two cell types
the big cells in this image are
dendritic cells and the smaller cells
are NK cells and anything else it's not
stained red or yellow are just Dappy
positive cells in the background here
and if we take a look at one cell and
its contact so we've one cell in the in
the middle of this image here and then
we have one two three four five six
contacts around it and we want to know
the distance or the the physical
properties of the the social contacts
between one cell and another cell but to
do that with a statistically saw a
robust matter we need to actually
measure every single cell so contact
that's in this image and then normalize
it to what we expect by random and by
doing that we end up with something that
is very robust against some number
changes against proliferation or cell
death for instance or against plate
movement or accidents this has also been
published in Nature Chemical Biology
last year you can take a look at the
algorithms and we utilize but generally
speaking the interaction is four and
what I'll discuss again the physical
interaction or movement of cells is the
number of observed interactions in an
image over the number of interactions
that are expected by random and that
gives us
robust score of physical contacts of
cells so we can recapitulate a couple
things that are known to start about the
immune system again I had mentioned
earlier that a big processing then
involves social contacts are a PCS
antigen presenting cells and T cells v
MHC 2 and what we can do is we can try
to add an MHC to block into the system
and see if we can measure properties
that are changing after the addition of
this block and in fact this on the
right-hand side you'll see in naive
state looking at this is on dendritic
cells 2 t cell so the interaction
between DCs and T cells we add in that
MHC 2 block in a naive state we see a
reduction of this interaction if we do
it in the background of obviously
infections or propagation of the immune
system we also see a drop so the first
one in naive is probably scanning the
second is signaling through the MHC and
here lastly Oh PS we don't see that
interaction change with the addition of
the MHC 2 block given that probably LPS
has not presented on MHC 2 so we can not
only recapitulate what we expect what
would happen if we add in a macy to
block in but we can see it changing
depending on the pathway that's
activated we can also recapitulate what
is known or the mechanism action of
approved drugs such as your troops
remodeled into a mob both work by
bringing effector cells whether there be
NK cells or T cells in to the physical
looks like connection between B cells
and they kill off that target B cell on
the left hand side we look at the
interaction between B cells and NK cells
and is we've increasing concentrations
rituximab which you can see on the black
line we have an increase in interaction
score and a decrease of the target cell
so we're killing off at b cell as the
interactions I was going up let's with
rituximab on the right within a 2-mile
we see the same thing so even though
we're killing off the b cell we're still
seeing an increase of interaction score
so again it's robust to changes in cell
number so these were small examples we
can actually use this in fairly large
throughput and screening this is 1,400
drugs that we had done this is collapsed
onto its keg and Kemble annotations
we're looking here at B cells T cells
macrophages and DCs and their
interaction profiles in the background
of a virus infection that we use to just
start the stimulation
blue or cells that are coming together
right ourselves we're coming apart and
then we can see how drugs in this system
possibly affect these interactions of
these scores well we found this library
was made up of about 50% fda-approved
drugs and 50% small molecule compounds
and we found was about 12% of the drugs
we used and in fact about 10% of all
fda-approved drugs in this in this
screen had some sort of immunomodulatory
phenotype which was quite cool just to
give you one example if we take a look
at statins sudoko a reductase inhibitors
they decrease the interaction between
dendritic cells and T cells and in 2001
there's a paper public statins
selectively inhibit leukocytes function
antigen won by by binding to a novel
regulatory integrated site so we're
recapitulating also what is known about
certain drugs and their effect on
various cell types but we wanted to find
something that was unknown to see if we
could actually work on a pathway of a
drug that had a potential I mean a
moderate ory effect that may be in the
background of its normal mechanisms of
action so we looked at the family on the
top left hand side if we look at the
family of receptor protein tyrosine
kinase inhibitors in which we have four
here we can see that there's an increase
selectively of C D 11 C positive cells
probably dendritic cells and CD 3
positive cells from BT cells there is an
increase in that relationship and it
turns out that two of these protein
tyrosine kinase inhibitors a
chrysanthemum both R and s enantiomers
were causing an increase of this
physical interaction profile we
published the pathway or the mechanism
that we had found to do this I'll just
give you a brief overview so on on the
right hand side you'll see effect plot
here you have dendritic cells or CD 11 C
positive cells on also MHC 2 when we
film that prasanta that was increasing
the expression of MHC 2 on dendritic
cells and in fact was doing the same
with MHC 2 and MHC 1 on APCs in general
and also cancer cells and here we have
the model here we believe that
presumptive and also a like molecule BSM
BMF seven seven seven 601 was blocking
in the
of the receptor msp1 are causing any
increase of downstream MHC progression I
skipped over the model only because it's
published and for time and you can take
a look at that but it's quite
interesting to know the TK I which he
has approved for lung cancer I possibly
has some sort of you know majah Tori
effect in the background here so the
summary of the second part of them I
talked of the quantification of Sailor
proximity can be a surrogate readout for
affected immune function
immunomodulatory screening can be a new
dimension into screening campaigns or
can be used to interpret de novo drugs
and antibodies by specific parties all
induced stuff cell contacts and we don't
currently or it is not common to look at
the social context of immune function as
a readout of how well these items or
these potential therapeutics are working
my take-home message from this webinar
and from this talk from a consequent
technology can be used for many things
including precision and translational
medicine and we look forward to let's
say closing out the clinical trial which
is still recruiting becoming to a close
now de novo drug discovery and drove
repurposing and molecular systems
biology and regarding precision medicine
and precision technologies or precision
diagnostics my assumption is a
combination of many of these
technologies both and functional so
different types of functional drug
screening and pen genetic to different
types of genetics were likely be needed
to meet the challenges of predicting
clinical response so with that I just
want to reiterate that these projects
were performed when I was a postdoc at
SEM the Center for molecular medicine
the Austrian Academy of Sciences in the
laboratory of the Doozer Creek you
forgot in collaboration with the
Department of hematology the Medical
University of Vienna
professor Willy Jaeger this work was
done in also collaboration with Baron
Schneider who co-invented this workflow
with me who is now at the professor of
the who is now a professor of eth now
professor at CTIA Zurg pardon me
along with Nicholas crowd who is now the
CEO of all site woman everyone else from
Sam who either helped in the first two
projects you
on the functional screen site or in the
genetics and also on the right hand side
you'll see a number of physicians who
not only entrusted us with their patient
samples also but who also entrusted us
to help them treat their patients
through this clinical trial from SEM and
also their feedback on not only is
technology like this necessary for the
clinic but as key opinion leaders what
could really help them and we are very
enthusiastic to continue our
relationship both from SEM and the
medical university with with all side so
with that I thank you everyone for
tuning in and I look forward to taking
any questions I can so thank you so much
thank you dr. vladimer for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the answer your question box located
on the far left your screen and we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for so let's get started our
first question is both programs the
differential cell death ennemy
immunomodulation seemed like very data
heavy processes both from raw image
collection and the downstream image
analysis point of view can you comment
on the pipelines or systems that you use
for this yeah absolutely
so it's a funny story also also does a
startup company and we aim to collect
data quickly and we aim to process data
quickly and to do this robustly you need
a fairly large computation on that work
and professionally maintained cluster
that we just do not have so we teamed up
or we utilize Google cloud platform in
order to process this data very quickly
and you can see a really nice overview
on our website of how we use the Google
workflow and how we put our analysis
software into a Google cloud that really
gives us unlimited power on bringing up
virtual machines and bringing up nodes
in order to analyze our data and do our
research quickly so we can get this data
either back into our customers hands or
patient hands
and our next question it seems that you
are mostly geared towards blood
malignancies do you have programs and
solid tumors or other diseases so right
now we're really focused on blood blood
malignancies we have one program that's
looking at purely fusion and ascites as
secondary indications for secondary
malignancies for solid tumor indications
- such as can we predict a drug response
in purely fusion that comes from late
stage lung cancer patient and can we
predict response of that lung cancer
patient the same for ovarian and other
GI tract cancers at the moment I can't
really comment on it regarding other
indications or other diseases such as
rheumatoid arthritis or other sterile
information yes but not as let's say
strong in progression as our blood blood
blood malignancy program now dr.
Vladimir do you do you do any specific
disease screening for immuno oncology
any sterile inflammatory inflammatory
disease for instance yes that's what I
was just referring to I am we don't have
any current programs that are looking at
inflammatory diseases although you know
any type of sterile inflammation will
have a huge background backbone of
propagation that relies on social
contacts and so if we can utilize our
workflows and look for social contacts
we could potentially target we could
create a new immunotherapies or new cell
based assays that could interrupt these
social contacts with us and reducing
let's say the burden or the inflammatory
burden on on the patient so it's
something we would really like to get
into Bob will say thank you doctor glad
Abreu do you have any final comments for
our audience just that we really like
collaborations we benefits both on
learning about our own technology but
also helping clinical need drug
discovery programs both on so let's say
cell death or immunomodulatory function
so if anyone has an interest please
don't hesitate to to reach out
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions any
questions we did not have time for today
we'll be adjusted by the speaker via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration we would like
to thank laberd's and our sponsor
PerkinElmer for underwriting today's
education webcast the house can be
viewed on-demand through june of 2019
laberd's will alert via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye